la planta química de azote en la
disputada localidad de severodonezk es
prácticamente el último foco de
resistencia
ucraniana en esta localidad lo han
confirmado fuentes británicas y también
ucranianas que han dicho que a las
tropas de moscú tienen el control de la
práctica totalidad de esta estratégica
ciudad recordemos que severodonezk es su
caída junto con la eventual caída de la
cercana lisas que significaría que rusia
tiene el control completo de la
provincia del lugar y también una
ventaja de cara a poder avanzar hacia
otras ciudades importantes de esta zona
como grama todos la guerra de esta
manera se enquista y se recrudece en el
este de ucrania donde se están
produciendo avances de las tropas de
moscú y en este contexto el gobierno
ucraniano ha vuelto a pedir una vez más
el envío de armas de largo alcance a
occidente el presidente ucraniano
wladimir
el esquí ha asegurado que no usará estas
armas contra la población civil en rusia